all right john a local nonprofit is now
expanding its pet food bank to meet a
surge in demand
we're talking about hearts alive village
it's now bringing free
and low-cost pet services to the
northwest part of the valley
our hector mojia live now this morning
with those details good morning hector
good morning alex the non-profit tells
me that the need shot through the roof
during the pandemic so they needed a
bigger space to host
and to hold their pet food and they
moved into that big warehouse across
this three
across the street and that's all thanks
to a grant
and they're helping low income families
in north las vegas as well as
the northwest but there's more to this
story hearts alive is also remodeling a
former pet hospital that's just
feet away from the new food bank the
nonprofit reports helping more families
during the pandemic than they have in
the past two years
one of their clients is douglas proha a
veteran who owns two cats
if clients like prohot don't have
transportation to pick up the food
volunteers go out of their way to drop
off supplies at their home for free
it means the world that i don't have to
worry about it and to be honest
like i've told them there'd been a
couple times where i had to steal
food just to feed them
i didn't like to admit to that but i had
to
because i couldn't see them suffer
it's a sad story and coming soon
hopefully in september a
center for low-cost clinic care pet
adoptions and grooming
generous donors helped hearts alive
acquire a shuttered pet clinic
once the renovations are complete it'll
be what's described as the first
non-profit
and full-service pet clinic in this
neighborhood and we're talking about a
big
project for hearts alive village they're
currently fundraising we'll talk a
little bit more about that
still ahead in the next half hour
reporting live from the northwest hector
mejia
8 news now